Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I can’t believe that I am saying but, but today
we are going to see how NVIDIA is getting
closer and closer to solving an almost
impossible problem. And that is, writing
real-time light transport simulations.
So, what is that? And why is it nearly impossible?
Well, if we wish to create a truly photorealistic
scene, in computer graphics, we usually reach
out to a light transport simulation algorithm,
and then, this happens. Oh yes, concept number
one. Noise! This is not photorealistic at all,
not yet anyway. Why is that? Well, during
this process, we have to shoot millions
and millions of light rays into the scene to
estimate how much light is bouncing around,
and before we have simulated enough rays, the
inaccuracies in our estimations show up as noise
in these images. This clears up over time, but it
may take from minutes to days for this to happen,
even for a smaller scene. For instance, this one
took us 3 full weeks to finish. 3 weeks! Ouch.
Now, earlier, we talked about this technique which
could take complex geometry, and 3.4 million light
sources, and it could really render not just
an image, but an animation of it interactively.
But how? Well, the magic behind all this is
a smarter allocation of these ray samples
that we have to shoot into the scene. For
instance, this technique does not forget what
we did just a moment ago when we move the camera
a little and advance to the next image. Thus,
lots of information that is otherwise thrown away
can now be reused as we advance the animation.
And, note that even then, these smooth,
beautiful images are not what we get directly,
if we look under the hood and look at the
raw result that comes out of a simulation, we
get something like this. Oh yes.
Still, a noisy image. But wait,
don’t despair! We don’t have to live with these
noisy images, we have denoising algorithms
tailored for light simulations. This one does
some serious legwork with this noisy input.
And, in a followup paper, they also went on to
tackle these notoriously difficult photorealistic
smoke plumes, volumetric bunnies, and even
explosions interactively. The results were once
again, noise filtered to nearly perfection. Not to
perfection, but a step closer to it than before.
Now note that I used the word interactively
twice here. I did not say real time.
And that is not by mistake. These
techniques are absolutely fantastic,
one of the bigger leaps in light
transport research, but, they still
cost a touch more than what production systems
can shoulder. They are not quite real time yet.
So, what did they do? Did they stop there? Well,
of course not, they rolled up the
sleeves and continued. And now,
I hope you know what’s coming. Oh yes! Have a
look at this newer paper they have in this area.
This is their result on the Paris Opera House
scene, which is quite detailed, there is a
ton going on here. And, you are all experienced
Fellow Scholars now, so when you see them flicking
between the raw, noisy and the denoised results,
you now know exactly what is going on. And, hold
on to your papers, because all this takes about 12
milliseconds per frame. Yes yes yes! My goodness!
That is finally in the real time domain
and then some! What a time to be alive!
Okay, so where is the catch? Our keen eyes see
that this is a static scene. It probably can’t
deal with dynamic movements and rapid changes
in lighting, can it? Well, let’s have a look.
Wow! I cannot believe my eyes. Dynamic movement,
checkmark. And here, this is as much changing in
the lighting as anyone would ever want, and
it can do this too. I absolutely love it.
And, remember the amusement park scene
from the previous paper? The one with 23
million triangles for the geometry,
and over 3 million light sources?
Well, here are the raw results, and after
denoising, this looks super clean. Wow.
So, how long do we have to wait for this?
This can’t be real time, right? Well,
all this takes is about 12 milliseconds
per frame. Again. And this is where I fell
off the chair when reading this paper. Of
course, not even this technique is perfect,
the glossy reflections are a little blurry at
places, and artifacts in the lighting can still
appear. But if this is not a quantum leap in
light transport research, I don’t know what is.
Plus, if you wish to see some properly detailed
comparisons against previous techniques,
make sure to have a look at the paper. And,
if you have been holding on to your papers,
now, squeeze that paper, because
everything that you see in this
paper was done by two people. Huge
congratulations Chris and Alexey!
And, if you are wondering if we
ever get to use these techniques,
don’t forget that their marbles demo is
already out there for all of us to use.
And it gets better, for instance, not many know
that they already have a denoising technique that
is online and ready to use for all of us. This
one is a professional grade tool right there. This
is really incredible, they have so many tools
out there for us to use, I check what NVIDIA
is up to daily, and I still quite often get
surprised about how much they have going on.
So, finally, real time light
transport in our lifetimes?
Oh yes, this paper is history in the making.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!